FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MORE THAN
A YEAR.
EVERYBODY HAD THEIR MICKEY EARS.
NEW COVID INFECTIONS ARE DOWN IN
23 STATES, AND MORE THAN 100
MILLION AMERICANS ARE FULLY
VACCINATED.
IN FIVE STATES, INFECTIONS ARE
INCREASING INCLUDING OREGON.
JONATHAN VIGLIOTTI'S IN THE
STATE CAPITAL WITH MORE ON THE
STORY.
GOOD MORNING.
WHY ARE THE NUMBERS STILL UP
THERE?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING TO
YOU, GAYLE.
GOOD QUESTION.
HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE TRYING TO
UNRAVEL THIS MYSTERY.
THEY SAY THAT VARIANTS AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNWILLING TO GET
VACCINATED COULD BE PLAYING A
ROLE HERE.
FOR THE SECOND WEEK IN A ROW,
THIS STATE LEADS THE COUNTRY IN
INFECTIONS.
THE GOVERNOR RECOGNIZES THAT
THESE NEW RESTRICTIONS WITH
GOING TO BE PAINFUL, ESPECIALLY
FOR BUSINESSES WHO ONLY JUST
REOPENED.
SHE SAYS THIS DECISION COULD
SAVE HUNDREDS OF LIVES.
AT THE PORTLAND INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT, STAFFERS ARE WORKING TO
VACCINATE AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE.
THE BEST WEAPON, OREGON
OFFICIALS BELIEVE, AGAINST THE
LATEST COVID SURGE.
DR. RENEE EDWARDS IS CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER AT OREGON HEALTH
AND SCIENCE UNIVERSITY.
>> IT'S HARD TO SEE ANOTHER
SURGE COMING NOW ESPECIALLY
SINCE SO MANY OF THE
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS NOW ARE
YOUNGER AND REQUIRING THE MOST
INTENSIVE INTERVENTIONS.
>> Reporter: THROUGHOUT MUCH OF
THE PANDEMIC, OREGON MANAGED TO
KEEP ITS CASES AND DEATH NUMBERS
LOW.
BUT OVER THE PAST FIVE WEEKS,
NEW INFECTIONS HAVE CLIMBED MORE
THAN 20% EACH WEEK, AND IN THE
PAST WEEK, HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE
NEARLY DOUBLED.
STATE HEALTH OFFICIALS HAVE
DETERMINED THE UK VARIANT, NOW
THE DOMINANT STRAIN IN THE U.S.,
IS ONE OF THE FACTORS DRIVING
THE INCREASE.
>> WE BELIEVE THAT THE VARIANTS
ARE MAKING PEOPLE SICKER, AND
ARE SPREADING MORE RAPIDLY.
EXACTLY WHY THE VARIANTS ARE
TRAVELING THIS WAY IN OREGON, I
CAN'T SAY.
BUT DEFINITELY IS CONCERNING.
>> Reporter: SO CONCERNING,
GOVERNOR KATE BROWN REINSTATED
RESTRICTIONS INCLUDING LIMITING
GYM CAPACITY AND BANNING INDOOR
DINING.
>> IT'S BEEN NUMBING AT THIS
POINT.
WE'VE TAKEN BLOW AFTER BLOW.
>> Reporter: BRIAN McMENAMIN WHO
OWNS SEVERAL OREGON RESTAURANTS
FEELS THAT BUSINESSES LIKE HIS
ARE BEING UNFAIRLY PUNISHED.
>> ALL THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS, THE SIX FEET OF
DISTANCING, THE MASKS, ALL THAT
STUFF, WE'VE BEEN DOING A GREAT
JOB.
GOING BACKWARDS DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE THE RIGHT OPTION NOW.
>> Reporter: STILL, STALE HEALTH
OFFICIALS SAY IT'S AN OPTION
THAT'S PROVEN EFFECTIVE AND ONE
THAT COULD HELP SLOW THE SPREAD
UNTIL MORE PEOPLE IN OREGON ARE
VACCINATED.
>> MANY STATES STILL HAVE MORE
VACCINATIONS TO DO.
AND AS WE REACH THE POINT WHERE
WE HAVE MORE VACCINES THAN
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BE
VACCINATED, THAT LEAVES ROOM FOR
COVID-19 TO SPREAD.
SO I DO THINK THERE'S A
CAUTIONARY TALE IN OREGON FOR
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY, AS
WELL.
>> Reporter: THE GOVERNOR HOPES
TO FULLY REOPEN THE STATE BY
JULY 1st.
IN THE MEANTIME, AN ADDITIONAL
$20 MILLION HAS BEEN APPROVED
FOR BUSINESSES HARDEST HIT.
TONY?
>> MILLIONS